think women have an over-inflated sense
of ego
I think my excuses yeah I feel like
being a really objective is very
difficult so if you are like not
conventionally attractive you've had to
come to terms with that and accept that
maybe you're obviously not
conventionally attracted can we just say
ugly
words where like they just meet like
it's the same thing but Less Direct
but you know what I mean yeah ugly so if
you're ugly okay so if you're ugly
um I guess that's very hard to come to
term with times with and I feel like if
I was if I thought I was ugly I'd be
like I'm gonna make a delusion I'm gonna
make a reality that that doesn't exist
because if you think you're ugly every
day I don't think you'd be very happy
but wouldn't it be better to like know
you're ugly and be like you know I'm a
fan of ugly man and be happy boom rather
than lizzo where she's like no but like
she doesn't realize she's ugly and so
now she's with a dude that's like
clearly with her for the money I mean
come on that's the problem in society
like women average women don't want to
date average men you think so average
women do not want to date I want to
agree with you but I can't because I see
so many women dating bums and so many
women that are dating like like you just
look at the woman and you're like wow
she's like a 10 out of 10. she's
beautiful she's got everything going for
her but you lie so you're not honest
about how girls look so I didn't say I
didn't I gave a rating of a five yeah
that's yeah but the girls with the girls
that are with the bums like they're
usually average because if they're above
average they would they would get an
above average guy but you would think
that women are insecure no I don't I
don't think so I think women think
they're hotter than they are most of the
time and usually if it is a bum he knows
how to talk and he's good looking like
girls don't date ugly bums if he's a bum
and he's usually hotter than her have
you seen Angelina Jolie I don't know who
she was dying but I just didn't find
that I don't know who it was it's 40
with six kids no no no no this was when
she was like young and I just looked at
the guy and I was like oh they're
together I don't remember who it was but
I found that like did he have money
that's why she left him and got Brad
Pitt so yeah she did she got money and
looks like that's a woman do I don't
know when going for a guy you want to go
you're going to go for the one that's
the someone you can sense can kind of
Take the Lead even if even if he's not
so much uh
if someone that you can be submissive
with and he's going to be the dominant
one then if he can take on that role
what he said like women fall in love
with what they hear yeah so the position
that he plays yeah and how he makes her
feel obviously us women wear like the
yeah I'll be your pretty thing you I
have all the looks don't worry you just
do everything else that's it tell them
again well if you don't
or if you don't leave a woman no like
let's say hypothetical scenario if
you're talking about people that have
been ugly what did they do then they
date each other
serious but the the problem the problem
is is women only swipe right on dating
apps 5 to 20 on the high end percent of
the time where men swipe right 50 of the
time yeah so it's a very small
percentage of men that are having sex
with everybody and so the guys the guys
that are eights nines and tens are
sleeping with the force fives and five
and sixes and they the girl the average
girls think they're on that level but
they're not they think they're hotter
than they are and that's fact and so
then and so then when they get their
husband the guy that would actually take
them seriously they think they're
settling because but that's really just
the guy on their level but they've been
sleeping with they've been sleeping too
high
but I think that comes from the fact
that
a lot of women are born of value whilst
men have to create their value yeah so
with women you're always afforded to see
the sexual Marketplace which means that
you're going to get a 10 looking guy who
just wants to have quick sex and you're
going to seek to validate Yourself by
getting an attractive guy so you're
gonna get you're going to give that guy
quick sex but then you now think that
I'm on that same level as that guy
because you're afforded to see it almost
sexual Marketplace again what you mean
by like
I don't know like having that advantage
of
um having the privilege like when you
want to find like casual sex women do
have that but I don't think women are
that naive to think that they can have
casual sex with a guy that that guy
would do would have a relationship with
me some women some women are like and
nobody will I'll give you an example so
on the last show I I said or it was a
show or two ago I asked the guys like
have you ever slept with a girl that
you'd never be seen in public with a
bunch said yes and then I was like and I
was like okay how long did you let that
go on and some of them said like five
six months yeah and so those that girl
like may think it's going somewhere but
it's going nowhere yeah and like they're
they're like they're low-key embarrassed
they were talking about how they need to
wash like shower after yeah
is that kind of like like an ethical
like why do men want to do that that's
how well that's how hardwired so unless
a man has discipline he naturally falls
into that style all those
characteristics that's just how men are
have you slept with someone that you
regret 100 to what degree like I
remember busting a nut and thinking God
why do I do this I went Church no it's
not Curry I went to church at Boston I
went straight to traffic hell talking
about this
ugly women what the hell am I I'm out
here slaying dragons like I'm awful
what's going on but that's the thing
with men though like you're luckily for
women are your standards on the floor
like if you have the free will to do
that though that was her choice and this
is why I always be me personally I speak
about discipline I've gone on Journeys
like I took a year at six to learn
sexual discipline for these reasons to
get what I'm saying in my Prime when I
was mad young at University I did it for
the sole purpose I believe it's
important but I still say that's a man's
choice because again that's your
biological imperative right now in
society we cater to a woman's biological
imperative which is to be more
monogamous if we was to live by our true
means our strategy for survival is
scattergun that's why we that's how we
have so much
um
sperm
we literally because what men are Were
Expendable we die we go to war we take
risk so in order for our linear region
to survive we need to impregnate as many
people as possible so if we was to live
by our rule biological Imperial if we'd
be out here spreading our seed and
we get we get demonized for being
natural whereas
women can we can cater to your um
biological imperative and you know it's
so funny I think women do get also
demonized if we're talking about black
men no no like I'm not talking about
when you were talking about like
spreading your seed in that like
um women that have a lot of kids with a
lot of different men aren't really
um seen as very attractive in society
but that's like the natural way no no
it's not but but it is no no the natural
way is for women to reproduce with the
highest value guy possible and it's in
society we push that says get that bag
yeah go for a future shot like that I
understand that but we're talking about
like you're talking about spreading your
seed and lots of different men how to do
that with lots of different women so
that means a lot of different women I'm
going to get pregnant a lot like quite
often and women with a lot of children
with different men no it's not it's not
by so they get pregnant by the highest
value guy possible so like throughout
history it would be like one man and a
bunch of concubines like how many how
many people are really related to
Genghis Khan
so it's like polygeny so when the man
has multiple women
because he's able to if he's able to
look after those women then he has kids
from mobile women and they will raise
their children together yeah 8 000 years
ago it was 17 women for one man and only
historically 40 of men have reproduced
where 80 of women have and so like
historically even men reproducing was a
privilege
yeah but like when men reproduce it's a
privilege but like
it's also natural for women to get
pregnant that's not seen as a privilege
like women like it's natural to get
pregnant by one guy not not but you can
get biologically like you can get
pregnant more than once yeah you can see
when we get pregnant just not at the
same time well you're right by it would
be by the same guy it would be like
tribes so basically like I'm talking
like
if men were just spreading the seat with
anyone like now uh-huh women could also
just get pregnant quite often it would
be like in tribes so basically like the
men would impregnate the like okay the
men and the women would have kids right
and then if a better like Warrior took
over the tribe they would kill the kids
take the women and so like men are
biologically repulsed by other people's
children like they're just designed to
not want to deal with other people's
kids and pass on their resources to them
you think so yes yeah not only that but
it was a study that was I was gone would
you would you date a single mom no
are you gonna buy the single moms or the
kids
I guess McDonald's foods
to me I just see you're just gonna give
you a kid I just don't want all that
baggage in it that's to me that's
unnecessary headache when there's a
bunch of other women who haven't made
that mistake aren't Men supposed to be
providers like traditionally for the
next man's you yeah yeah but like if
you're at the head of the tribe like
Pearl said earlier and you have multiple
wives
the only way they live is collective and
you'll be taking care of a lot of
children yeah but like back it no no no
in like olden times you wouldn't be
certain that is your child
you're right they wouldn't be certain
and that's why but that's that's why men
don't like hoes that's why they're
repulsed by girls that sleep around is
because they want to make sure that kid
is theirs
and it's an advantage you want to give
your resources to someone that's
actually your sister yes because like in
the past and you really wouldn't know
exactly in nature like that's why in
nature like you wouldn't we didn't have
paternity tests till the last 100 years
100 and so that's why men don't like
girls that have high body counts or have
slept around they can't even help it
it's just natural to them because they
don't want to pass on resources to
another man's kids as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible